Carol, what's the best way to deal with business owners that are ghosting or complaining about
the job size not even closing because they can't sell? This is one of the problems with giving away
free leads, right? Is they don't value it because I can guarantee if it was a lead that they got
from their own website or their own marketing or from even home advisors that they paid for,
they probably wouldn't be complaining. The only thing that I can say is that try to find out
upfront what it is that they're looking for and just let them know. Just like I talked about with
Luke just now, just let them know, say, hey, not all of these are going to be fat, juicy deals.
What are you looking for? What's your best? What's your second best? What's your third best?
What do you not want? And I'll try to get you as many good ones as I can and try to filter out
these other ones. But here's what I always let people know is like, yeah, I get it. That happens.
It's just part of the game. And I'll always mention that's the beauty of how we structure
these deals. I won't tell them flat fee. I'll say the beauty of the way that we're going to
structure this deal once we talk, and I know we're not going to talk right now, but when we do,
these type of jobs, when they come in, you don't have to run these jobs. You can do whatever. You
could throw them away. You give them away. You cannot answer the phone. It's going to be up to
you. We have a really nice deal structure that's going to allow you to do that. And in the back of
my mind, I'm thinking, oh, I'm going to do flat fee. And they don't have to run them because
they're not feeling like they're getting charged for every single lead because it's all included
in the same price. So I use that as just a way to make the flat fee even sweeter. But I don't bring
it up. I don't say, yeah, that's why we do flat fee. And I just say, hey, this is the beauty of
the way we structure this deal, which by the way, I'm going to talk about when we zoom here,
but yeah, if you don't like that, just don't run it. We'll get you another one, right? It's,
but again, I'm just giving you free leads, but they cost you nothing. So you may as well run it.
You may as well run it. It costs you nothing, right? That's what I would do.